no we're in Europe is free from
corruption that's just one result of the
anti-corruption report it says
corruption costs the economy at least
120 billion euros every year as much as
the entire EU annual budget corruption
erodes trust in public institutions and
democracy it undermines our internal
market it hampers for an investment it
costs taxpayers another point of serious
concern is party financing and monstrum
says Germany too needs reform for
example in the financing of election
campaigns where businesses have
especially strong influence over
political parties there are many
different ways of party financing and we
suggest more transparency when it comes
to who who finances the parties what are
the limits how do you publish it there's
also plenty of room for corruption when
politicians go into business often
producing enormous conflicts of interest
this is Angela Merkel's former chief of
staff at the Chancellery renaud pas fala
his potential switch from public service
to a highly paid job on the board of
rail operator Deutsche Bahn has provoked
outrage it stinks of corruption say the
critics and the EU report seems to agree
pointing to a general lack of integrity
Brussels wants a mandatory waiting
period for these kinds of appointments
and that's something the German
government has long promised which may
be part of the reason that Germany as a
whole got good marks from the EU when it
came to corruption